I was 22. I had done everything that my
dad had wanted me to do at this point
and so I started driving across the
country I called him when I was like
halfway across the United States and I
was like I'm going to California I'm
gonna open a gym I'm gonna get into
fitness and we didn't really talk much
for a long time
I knew that he just wanted me to be a
doctor that's what he was that would
have been his dream
it wasn't enough and I knew that and so
I knew that the choice for me was that I
either had to die to him or I had to die
to myself
because people say it's Society it's
other people it's usually one or two
voices
are you willing to sacrifice your dreams
are you willing to sacrifice a certain
amount of influence that your family has
over them
I felt like I had to let my dad's dream
die from mine to live
foreign